yo what is up everybody Mather we G here
with another Dark Souls 3 tutorial in
this video I'm gonna be showing you guys
every confirmed titanite slab location
in the game titanite slabs are essential
for fully upgrading your weapons so
you're going to want to get every single
one you can a little forewarning
spoilers for most of the areas in the
game because I'm going throughout the
whole game world alright let's get right
into it with number one you can find
your first slab by dragging the coiled
sword fragment with the Crows at the top
of Firelink shrine if you don't know
where or what the crows are check out my
other video about them if you don't have
the coiled sword fragment you're gonna
want to check out the wiki as its kind
of in-depth now to get there however a
way to fast mini guide to it is from the
lothric castle bonfire head to the
elevator head down the elevator through
the consume Kings Guardian over the
consume Kings dead body past the
illusionary wall through the darkness
through some more darkness over gun
dears 2.0 zon dead body up to dark fire
link and add the bonfire coming in
number two we're going to be starting
the grand archives bonfire head in to
the grand archives and press normally
stroll up to the second floor and in the
middle of the second floor there will be
a lever in between some cursing
bookshelves pull the lever and a wall
back on the first floor will drop down
you should be able to see it from where
you pull the lever head back down to the
first floor and behind that wall will be
a chest with your second titanite slab
for number three again we're gonna start
from the grant archives bonfire but this
time we're going to use the elevator
shortcut if you don't have this unlocked
progress through the grant archives like
normal you'll eventually get this
unlocked instead of progressing towards
the castle towards lothric pop a left
head up the stairs and continue over to
the adjacent roof get far enough into
the roof and three winged knights will
drop down these guys are pretty tough so
I suggest pulling them one by one to the
back roof and fighting them so low
they're pretty powerful but slow so back
stabs are a good way to kill them once
you kill the last one you'll be rewarded
with your third Titan xlab this reward
of a tightening slab only happens the
first time you kill all three however I
have heard rumors that titanite slabs
are a rare drop from killing these guys
in general I've killed these guys a lot
and I haven't been able to find it so I
can't confirm this however they might
drop it as a rare drop I don't know I
can't confirm this but you definitely do
get one the first time you kill all
three number four this is the last slab
we're gonna get from the grand archives
bonfire
you're going to need the short cut right
before the prince lothric bossfight
activated to do this that shortcut can
be found to the right directly before
the boss fight except there's a trick to
the shortcut ride the elevator down and
send it back up once it's back up and
you're on the lower level another
platform should show up this elevator
has two platforms just like the one in
the undead settlement that you first see
sig word step on the lower platform and
write it down once you get to the bottom
you'll be greeted with a lonely corpse
and your fourth slab this fifth slab is
really simple but it could be hard to
miss for this one you need to kill all
the Lords of cinder so go do that and
come back once he done that put their
cinders on their respective Thrones and
head to the shrine handmaiden she will
now sell you a tightening slab for
thirty thousand souls and a bit higher
if you've killed her a couple of times
and she's mad at you
slab number six will be found near the
third bonfire of arch dragon peak on the
opposite side of the peak from the
bonfire just head directly to the ocean
of the peak you will find a small room
with one of those rock dragon things and
a ladder at the top of the ladder you'll
be greeted with the possibly very
nostalgic view Havel the rack you can
choose to best the old knight of Glin or
you can choose not to there's a slab
right next to where he originally stands
near the dragon so you can run it and
pick that up or slay him and pick it up
at a more leisurely pace the seventh and
final slab is found again an art
striking peak this one's a bit harder
than the previous though bring the bell
near the third bonfire drop into the
mist and enter the boss fight this is a
very tough boss fight so it might take
you a while but be persistent and you'll
eventually get it defeat the nameless
King and gain access to the area below
walk over to the nearest corpse from the
bonfire that you spawn at and viola your
last slab hope you guys have enjoyed
this tutorial of how to get every type 9
slab inside of Dark Souls 3 or at least
everyone that I know of slash is
confirmed since I haven't been able to
find anything else on any other
locations for slabs you guys have
enjoyed this make sure you check out
more of my channel since I have a lot of
Dark Souls 3 content if you like directs
with reel or check out my law 3 Kingdom
lore video and stick around my channel
since I will be doing a lot more lower
stuff I thank you guys for watching and
peace out
you
you
you